hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast and how are you how's your week
going ah back to the grind huh
back to the [ __ ] grind you too oh
yeah I wish how we show how was your uh
how was your time off you have a nice
holiday did you did you did yeah oh yeah
how old is she now you haven't those
[ __ ] conversations oh the holidays
are over and it's back to the grind
then traffic go into your cubicle I
think I'm gonna kill my boss if I don't
drive into the wall um I actually had a
[ __ ] panic attack not a semi panic
attack sort of like I [ __ ] nose dives
into a bit of a depression yesterday
just take another [ __ ] year here we
go here we go again here we [ __ ] go
again we have a chemical problem with
the aircraft we're just going to pull
over here on the tarmac we have a
landing light that is inoperable at this
moment we're gonna sit tight here and
wait till on the mechanics come out here
which I do not have a estimated time on
at this point but I will we do that's
what information will I get back to you
suitably CAD and told that now it's
gonna be apologize for the delay and I
just trying to sit back and relax
specially care I've got to try to keep
the air on apologize if it gets a little
hot back there another [ __ ] year that
another [ __ ] year of that the shows
are great it's the getting the getting
to the shows um got people taking their
[ __ ] shoes I look if you take your
shoes off you have socks on I [ __ ]
get it alright just don't rub your feet
together I've talked about it before Mac
just can you not rub your [ __ ] feet
together the foot foot foot foot foot
and [ __ ] drives me nuts
I just uh I just want to punch the back
of the [ __ ] chair anyways what is
going on with me I'm gonna be on the
Colin Cowherd show today hyping f is for
family I'm going into Netflix today and
we're gonna do our little song and dance
and pitch them our season arc for season
two basically that's what you do after
you do the first water they do pretty
good but now where are you gonna go
where you gonna go with it now and then
you got to get in there yeah yeah that I
wouldn't do the doodle he does this she
does that give us some more [ __ ]
money please oh my god
we'll think about it then you everybody
walks out cool I think I could you think
I'm good I think wait good I know we're
here
what should we hear Tuesday Wednesday at
the latest I want to thank everybody for
flying friendly skies here today yeah
unfortunately we're dealing a little bit
of weather in the dallas-fort Worth area
we're number 72 in line unfortunately
it's really nothing we could do here be
patient I'm gonna try to make up some
time over in the air you travel a little
faster a little more fuel we put our own
hole in the ozone layer you know another
year of that but you know what else you
know sometimes you know I don't know
every once in a while I just [ __ ]
drive down the street I just see a
homeless guy laying on the sidewalk
sleeping you know and as much as
uncomfortable as it is you just looking
just like you know I would [ __ ] love
to do that right now
just pull over and lay down on the
ground and take a [ __ ] nap now I
don't want to live outside and granted I
know that that homeless guy is sleeping
during the day because at night that's
when the people come up out of the sewer
drains like in [ __ ] Escape from New
York you know because they have to feed
so when you're homeless you got to be up
at night you know a lot of people taking
a nap in the middle of the [ __ ]
afternoon that's because at night right
these having like a [ __ ] you know a
two-by-four fight
fighting up yeah right he's dealing with
that [ __ ] so but I like the NAP part of
it I'm actually looking at the homeless
guy's life the way a woman looks at a
man's life like that looks I want to do
that I don't want to pay the price for
it but I'd like that in my life equal
rights all right I go on Facebook
because I'm an old white guy I love I
love the Facebook I absolutely love it I
didn't give a [ __ ] even if I delete my
account they never delete it because of
that creepy [ __ ] who I judged by the
actor who played him I don't even know
what the real Zuckerberg looks like said
his name
oh I [ __ ] up the other day I said
Lamar Lundy instead of Lamar Hunt he was
the original owner of the Dallas Texans
Lamar Lundy was part of the fearsome
foursome and what's funny is that's the
[ __ ] name I can never remember you
know when they go name the fearsome
foursome I'm always like all right Rosie
queer Merlin Olsen uh Deacon Jones and
Lamar Lundy's like the bass player in a
huge band right you could never name the
bass player you know unless they're
really if they're unless they're like
one of those frontman bass players like
Steve Harris you know Billie Sheen and
you know back in the day John and
twistle you know or they play in a trio
cuz then you only have to remember three
names but if they play in a band of four
or more people you just can never
remember the bass players name you know
Lamar Lundy is that all right what's
what's the front floor for the Steelers
I don't think I could name that was me
Joe Greene LC Greenwood Dwight white and
and the bass player what the [ __ ] was
his name it's a great name - that's a
[ __ ] shame I'm gonna have to look
that up I have to look that up like he
can't disrespect - [ __ ] it 70 Steelers
they went for a tow and titles you can't
you can't disrespect the team you know
whose fan base I'm not gonna get into it
all right way to go Steelers front four
there's a bunch of people in [ __ ]
there's a bunch of people in Pittsburgh
right now screaming at their [ __ ] the
Steel Curtain who were they the Steel
Curtain yada yada yada yada yada Mean
Joe green LC Ernie [ __ ] Holmes what a
great name
Ernie Holmes was coming down an irony
Holmes you know he's gonna be at least
six five anyways there weren't any man's
names left anymore do they
this is coming from a guy named pill
won't you come home Bill Bailey let's go
back here what I don't want oh here's
what I wanted to talk about the the Los
Angeles rant that the st. Louis Rams /
Los Angeles lion tram slash clean huh /
Cleveland Rams they're coming back their
comment back I'm so psyched that they're
coming back I'm so psyched that it was
the Rams and not the Chargers or the
Raiders hey I'm so [ __ ] excited okay
la does not need the Chargers or hey we
don't need them stay away okay
la needs two Rams blue and yellow the
Rams the Los Angeles Rams that's what
they need they don't need they don't
need the [ __ ] they don't need to
bring the Raiders but if you bring the
Raiders back the city of Los Angeles if
you bring the Raiders back you're
basically signing
on the fact that someone's gonna get
stabbed or shot it's just it's a fact
just watch the thirty four thirty on the
[ __ ] Los Angeles Rams the one that
Ice Cube narrates the way he's talking
and all that [ __ ] it's [ __ ] it's
actually inadvertently like hilarious
it's just the level of like la doesn't
eat you don't know you don't [ __ ] eat
it somebody's gonna like they can't
handle they can't handle those colors
they can't handle the pirate on this
side we keep it in [ __ ] Oakland where
people just dress up like it's gonna be
a musical and even then somebody got
shot at a [ __ ] 49ers Raiders like a
pregame thing you don't need it you know
it's funny everybody always talks about
the Philly fans and how East Coast fans
oo Yankees Red Sox it's nothing compared
to out here people die out here guy went
to a [ __ ] Dodgers game with this kid
and had on a giant's Jersey and he he
has brain damage for the rest of his
[ __ ] life because this [ __ ] e22
guys jumped them while his kids sat
there and watched that was at a [ __ ]
baseball game
the Rams that's it hi
where are the Rams perfect you don't
need the autumn wind was it Reid you
don't need to bring that to the Inland
Empire to do that I'm telling you and
I'm basing charger fans on the one
[ __ ] charger game that I [ __ ] went
to and I hope you know me and law had
almost got into a fight when we were
there and I was rooting for the Chargers
I just had a Patriots hat on it was an
old-school Patriots head it was all
[ __ ] beat-up they were playing the
[ __ ] Colts I'm cheering the Chargers
that alone I mean I expected to get a
little bit of [ __ ] right a little bit of
[ __ ] but to get to the point that it's
gonna be a physical confrontation and
somebody dumps a beer on you and that
type of [ __ ] all my bad but they did it
on purpose like yeah [ __ ] that
keep those [ __ ] animals where they're
at keep them where they're at like just
you know keep the Rocky Horror Picture
Show in the end zone keep that up and
[ __ ] Oakland plus it's the Oakland
Raiders
stay a [ __ ] see I'm kind of giving I
invert Lee give an Oakland [ __ ] I don't
mean to do that it's the Oakland Raiders
all right
they came down here before they tried to
make it in Hollywood
they couldn't you know they got a couple
of guest stars on the fall guy you know
then they did an episode of full house
and then it just sort of dried up for
and then they they put their tail
between their legs they went back home
they took over their dad's business I
don't understand why are they coming
back and why everybody all at once all
of a sudden everybody wants to come here
we've been sitting here for 20 [ __ ]
years without a team now all of a sudden
everybody wants to come back the RAM
should come back there Los Angeles's
team all right now I know the Chargers
started here in LA like their first
their first year or two on the AFL but
uh yeah keep them down in San Diego
you know city you want to understand by
standing with San Diego is a great place
it's where I'm most mellow great places
when you go down there you're like this
is everything that LA should be it's
chill it's [ __ ] relaxed you got the
weather this is great it's not the grind
of LA that's what San Diego feels like
when I go down there [ __ ] love it
but then for whatever [ __ ] reason you
go to a sporting event and these people
turn into [ __ ] maniacs not a Padre
game just a charger games they just have
[ __ ] animals I don't know maybe if
they built them a nicer Stadium and then
they gave my mascot I have no idea but I
do think it's really [ __ ] up that you
know the Raiders are gonna leave because
you know and the Chargers are gonna
leave and st. Louis is leaving basically
because they don't like their stadiums
and they're throwing a [ __ ] temper
tantrum it's the NFL is so [ __ ] up man
but sports in general that they do that
to people it's like dude it's your
league it's your [ __ ] business you
know what I mean
you don't like your [ __ ] place of
work you know build another one I don't
know this but there's no way to organize
people to get them just to to stand up
to owners
right like I remember here when I was
working in Indianapolis in Indianapolis
you know they played at the was at the
Hoosier dome or whatever when they were
building that Lucas Oil Field this taxi
driver when I was there was telling me
that that the city well they weren't
even done paying off the RCA Dome or
whatever the [ __ ] they called it they
they won't even done paying that off and
then they had this [ __ ] thing if
you've never been to Indianapolis I
don't know if the art the Hoosier dome
RCA Dome whatever the [ __ ] it was called
if that's still standing but when they
were [ __ ] building Lucas Oil Field
and it was right next to the the old one
which I believe is torn down you could
fit like two of those inside the new one
and stack two on top of each other the
size of this [ __ ] new one I can only
imagine how much taxpayers have to pay
for that [ __ ] it's [ __ ] stupid
the whole thing's [ __ ] stupid I
really believe that once you make a
stadium that should be a stadium and you
just keep fixing the [ __ ] thing up
the way I'm fixing up my [ __ ] of a
house sorry I just discovered something
else that was [ __ ] up with my house
but you know what right now I'm the
stubborn German Irish guy and me I'm
just like you know what bring it up sink
every [ __ ] dime I have into this
goddamn taking on water [ __ ] of a
boat I'm done I'm [ __ ] done like I'm
having somebody come over today to look
at my garage and somebody built off of
my office here they built this closet
and they extended this room itself and I
don't know who's friend of a friend
built this [ __ ] thing but it
literally sits right above my garage and
on these two wouldn't like I don't even
know what the terminology is they're not
two by fours was it four by sixes
whatever it's wood and that's always
bothered me and then down all right I
talked about this in the last podcast
but beneath that is my garage and in my
garage right underneath that wood is a
steel beam that goes across the garage
there's a steel beam going down one side
and not on the other
because there's a window there so they
said well forget supporting the entire
[ __ ] structure let's put a window
here so I can look at my neighbor's
house that's [ __ ] six inches away
yeah one of the first thing I did when I
bought the house is I put a shade up and
pulled it down and I've never brought it
back up again until the other day when
the guy looked so anyways I think when
you get like a stadium like just just
fix the [ __ ] thing up just fix it up
and keep fixing the [ __ ] thing up and
that's it what are you - have you ever
ever gotten tickets into a luxury box it
sucks it sucks the food sucks
you're 9 million miles away from the
game you now the upper deck is further
away from the game it [ __ ] blows I
wish you guys you young people out there
I wish back in the day you could have
gone to like like the Boston Garden
make-believe garden I mean I never went
to a game there I took a tour of the
place but I'll just go with the ones
that I went to the old [ __ ] Boston
Garden dude you were on top of the
[ __ ] game it was like Thunderdome
when you were you were in the upper deck
of those [ __ ] stadiums dude you
literally felt like if you lean too far
forward you're gonna fall down and you
would hit the ice
that's how steep it was but now they're
like the fire code and you know to get
the [ __ ] elephants out you know it's
gotta be [ __ ] more chill you know
I've relaxed grade I don't know I'm not
into it but I'm psyched that the Rams
are back I feel like the Rams should be
there
I feel like San Diego should be in San
Diego I feel like Oakland should be in
Oakland you know like the way it was
when I was a kid and that's it and I
know I was kind of [ __ ] rough on
[ __ ] LA fence but it's true Anaheim I
went down to Anaheim one time we would
share it on the Red Sox we had on our
Red Sox [ __ ] you know but we weren't
[ __ ] about it
I swear Red Sox suck stuff into Yankee
Stadium and people would break my balls
chance some [ __ ] and point at me when I
laughed it off and they saw that I was a
good [ __ ] or whatever then they were
then they were do they I wait how long
you down here in New York I live down
here
really but blah blah blah blah you know
and then they'd score and they'd [ __ ]
laugh at me and give me [ __ ] or whatever
and you know and if we scored what won
the game
I wouldn't [ __ ] point at him and
stuff I wasn't a I wasn't a dick alright
cuz he's my thing if you go to a stadium
with the other jersey you got to expect
to get some [ __ ] alright but like once
you demonstrate that you're not gonna be
a [ __ ] obnoxious ass people should
leave you alone you know what I mean
you're just making a road trip you show
in the other stadium respect that you
wanted to come and see it and that
should be the [ __ ] end of it and
that's was my experience when I was
living in New York I came out here and
it's just like now I'm gonna stab you in
the [ __ ] neck so well actually you
know I'm always bitching about the
population problems you know what [ __ ]
all that [ __ ] the last 18 minutes of
this podcast bring their age it's bring
them down here maybe some people will
[ __ ] die it'll be a couple less
people procreating you know bill did you
really have to take it to there yeah I
think I did um alright you know what
that kind of reminds me of though is the
these [ __ ] people who are baiting
Trump supporters no I'm not I'm not
gonna you know get into politics here
but you know you gotta call a spade a
spade here I mean that those people are
mouth-breathing morons and Trump is up
there not saying anything and getting
them to go absolutely [ __ ] nuts and
it's actually it's like watching a movie
where they're kind of warning you about
who I don't know now when I watch Trump
when I listen to what he says it reminds
me of like that's some couple of
Hollywood movies that I've seen and the
person running for office is just so
over the top and ridiculous it just
reminds you that you're watching a movie
and just like why did they go that far
they just [ __ ] dialed it back a
little bit I this could be a little more
believable and I'd have a much better
much better movie and then along came
Trump and uh you know I owe all of those
movies an apology but I do have to say
this the [ __ ] nerds who went to one
of the latest Trump rallies and had a
sign obama's a good president this
country already is great but
that you just went in there you know you
went in there to pick a fight and then
they videotaped it and when they tore up
your side's what you knew they were
gonna do you get to be like Trump's
supporters have hit a new low I guess
the reason why they're doing that right
now which is really what that is is
basically entrapment that's like they
throw drugs at your feet ah what's that
no that's actually not so what if like
though some smokin hot chick you just
walk up to some fatty and she's just
like hey you want me to suck your dick
give me 20 bucks he's like okay let me
finish this muffin and the cops just
come in you can't [ __ ] do that you
can't tempt you can't tempt somebody
like them and I feel like that's kind of
what they did with them but um haven't
said all that yeah that Trump thing stop
being funny like a good four to six
months ago and it's just like wait a
minute is this guy gonna get the
nomination you know all I'm begging for
just give me two reasonable human beings
two sane reasonable human beings you
don't I mean that kick you know on
either [ __ ] side and then give me
that third [ __ ] option just be
[ __ ] reasonable then walk around I'm
gonna bomb the [ __ ] out of so it's the
[ __ ] is wrong with you it's always the
guys who don't have to go over there do
well you know I'm [ __ ] I'm the tough
guy behind the [ __ ] desk I can't
believe nobody slept that wig off yet
you know all right let's uh let's plow
ahead as somebody who's trying to keep
up with both hockey and basketball
this is what ends up happening you just
end up watching your own teams and you
don't know what the rest of the league
is doing and that's what's going on with
me because I used to check in with the
Dallas Stars and uh and the the
Blackhawks and the and the LA Kings that
just teams I really like watching and I
haven't had a chance to so I just been
watching the Bruins [ __ ] lose lose
lose on this road trip you lost to
Jersey then we lost to [ __ ] did we
no he beat Jersey right we beat Jersey
and we've lost three in a row we lost to
the Flyers the rages in Ottawa I will
say honor was them was the most
enjoyable loss because it's my belief
that the best thing in sports right now
is three-on-three overtime hockey even
if you [ __ ] everybody who [ __ ]
about hockey this is the hockey you want
to see no fights racing up and down the
ice and someone's get basically gonna
score within five [ __ ] minutes you'll
love it I don't know if there's any
YouTube videos you can watch the whole
[ __ ] overtime play the Ottawa bruins
overtime it was it was we lost and I was
I almost stood up and applauded it was
that [ __ ] enjoyable to see was
incredible it's all mostly when you
watch it you like you know what maybe
there's too many people playing
professional hockey I want to take
anybody's job but if it was three on
three from the get-go Jesus Christ the
whole [ __ ] game you know what what
happened somebody would die the cardio
would just be off the [ __ ] has
anybody interviewed a NHL player yet to
say like what is it like what's it like
to take a shift during like three on
three overtime versus when it's five on
five not including the goaltender's okay
for all you [ __ ] number nerds out
there like what is that like
are you more winded is there an
unbelievable freedom because you don't
have to worry about getting checked it's
gonna be [ __ ] incredible feeling like
you're playing pond hockey anyways and
then the [ __ ] Celtics they finally
won last night of course I missed the
goddamn game I just saw them two [ __ ]
loss to the Knicks do that porzingis guy
holy [ __ ] he's like a ten-foot Larry
Bird he was looking like that in the
first quarter this guy was just hitting
1 3 after another then he took one shot
3-point shot this guy's like 7 foot 2 or
3 or something he took a 3-pointer from
like funny look like he was like 8 feet
behind the arc they just went whoosh and
what's funny is what's each three that
he hit the [ __ ] noises that the crowd
was making like basically this is the
guy I think this is the guy
like he'd hit one they like they cheer
but you hear like underneath the cherry
here oh then he hits a second one then
the third one I like freaking the [ __ ]
out and you can tell
melih loves [ __ ] playing with them
that pass into each other it was [ __ ]
great
so I'm sitting there watching it going
like all right if we're gonna lose these
guys at least I get to watch you know
the older star having fun with the new
kid you know see it's just really fun to
watch the two of them playing and Jesus
Christ God help the league if they get a
[ __ ] point guard huh well I'm not the
whole league but I mean they could [ __ ]
with the Cavaliers couldn't they maybe I
don't know [ __ ] about hoop I'm gonna
shut up but I enjoyed watching them play
and everything's going great I got see
you know when I'm gonna watch the rest
of this [ __ ] game and who knows maybe
I'll watch one of these guys put up 40
right who knows and then I'll set it all
went to [ __ ]
Mallos backing up the [ __ ] court the
refs standing there he steps on the refs
40 turns his [ __ ] ankle and then
that's it
it's [ __ ] it he tried coming back out
after the half and then he just said
[ __ ] it left I'm out I dropped my
[ __ ] 20 for the evening I'll see and
he [ __ ] leaves I saw the other night
he's still not [ __ ] playing cuz he
stepped on the refs foot so he keep
[ __ ] leaves so my car let's see if
that the kid can lead the team here and
then next thing you know he's got like
five [ __ ] files and he's sitting down
and this is funny this funny things we
still lost the goddamn game I actually
love the Celtics they young and
everything but they they love scoring
like 35 in the first quarter you know
and going up by 10 12 19 I watched him
lose to Memphis they having a 19-point
[ __ ] lead and I don't know I still
like him I think it just [ __ ] hang on
to a goddamn lead I could enjoy it a
little bit more but by the way so last
night they were playing the paces and
one of the [ __ ] most fucked-up things
ever I was sitting out looking at the
Pacers wearing these uniforms I'm like
where do I know those uniforms from
and I looked it up online they were
wearing the uniforms the same uniforms
that they wear in that movie Hoosiers
right am I correct in assuming that let
me look this up before I make fun of
them for actually doing that Hoosiers
movie images it's all gonna be gene
Hackman's face right yeah they were
wearing those things do you realize how
[ __ ] up that is hey black guys why
don't you put on these uniforms that
white people used to wear when you
weren't allowed to play the second I saw
it I wouldn't say unless it witness
those are [ __ ] one who's [ __ ]
white whitey vers whitey the all-white
days right look at the pictures the
picture of the [ __ ] team in black and
white that they were doing all right
number 43 white number 15 white number
53 white 25 white 13 white 12 white 14
white the other guy can't read his
number they're all white
whitey why would you have them wear
those
why didn't you gonna have the the color
barrier broken uniforms one day this
year I don't seem like an odd [ __ ]
choice to me however Indiana has such a
weird [ __ ] such a weird [ __ ] state
you know it's really just like you know
just odd golly gee aw shucks
white people / astoundingly racist you
know like as much [ __ ] as Boston like
the only places that gets [ __ ] for being
racist basically it's the south in
Boston Massachusetts and having been on
the road I don't know how [ __ ] long
speak in there we had all there's no
worse is when the when you're still at
the gate they're just like touching
everybody on American Airlines flight
191 flight crew to show up so it's
probably gonna be another 40 minutes if
you'd like to get something to eat but
don't want it too far
that [ __ ] what do you know why I just
went into that how do you [ __ ]
remember if you know what and I've been
I've been doing this long enough to just
say [ __ ] that idea I'm just gonna
continue one all right so we got
Patriots first the Chiefs this weekend
in playoffs football playoffs and I
think that we could possibly win that
game by the skin of our teeth
it all depends on who comes back but if
we do not have an offensive line then I
our goose is cooked because our starting
running back I can't even remember his
[ __ ] name he's been out for so long
you know I really need to just pick a
sport you can't [ __ ] watch him off
that's what I'm trying to do I'm
watching the Patriots Bruins and Celtics
and I don't even know anybody [ __ ]
name any mice know the [ __ ] lines are
the Bruins I don't even know I'm just
sitting there you know what is it this
is my [ __ ] I don't know what what the
psychological term is is like I'm gonna
I'm gonna get there I'm gonna watch the
Bruins watch all the Bruins games watch
all the Bros games and then virzi comes
out get the basketball ha ha I'm just
[ __ ] sitting here binge watching this
[ __ ] like a maniac I think I need to
step back for a second and get my
priorities in order
and realized that the Patriots are in
the [ __ ] playoffs and the Bruins and
Celtics are still in the regular season
i-i'll just be paying attention to the
Patriots right but I don't know I think
I think see I think it's Seattle's I
think Seattle they had their [ __ ]
little you know when you win again the
way Seattle won last week which is
basically the other team basically
screws the pooch
you gotta start to feel like you're kind
of a team a destiny right and I know one
year the Patriots you know the Ravens
missed a field goal and that got us into
a Superbowl but uh that one made me feel
like we backed in but like I really
think like Seattle if it wasn't [ __ ]
nine degrees out or ten below zero I
thought that was really in the Vikings
favor kind of slowed them down a little
bit
evened out the field and I can say that
knowing nothing about the Vikings I'm
gonna shut the [ __ ] up right now how
about that would that be all right
anyways well that's the half hour here I
got to uh I got to go [ __ ] put on my
monkey suit here to make sure that I
look like I'm from Indiana when I go in
to go pitch the second season here so
anyways thank you everybody for
listening to the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast
just checking in on you
episode now we're gonna do a little
throwback [ __ ] I didn't see any
advertising for this week
maybe you listen to some advertising
right now that are recorded on my phone
on the way to the [ __ ] meeting I have
no [ __ ] idea what you're gonna hear
right now but I know eventually you're
gonna hear some throwback [ __ ] from
podcasts from a year gone by alright
have a great weekend you [ __ ] [ __ ] I
gotta read five of these [ __ ] things
the advertisements here this is not the
throwback part this is the advertising
part I guess I missed two of them on
Monday so here we go MVM t watches
everybody movement watches was started
by two college dropouts we're flunkies
man with the idea to make quality
watches that don't break the bank
starting at 95 bucks and sold online
they cut out all the [ __ ] retail
markup supposedly movement sent some
watches over here question mark I guess
that wasn't supposed to read that yeah
they did they write they I got them
they're great
I'm not lying I have them in my closet
I'm not wearing them you know but I
liked them quality material and sleek
design the perfect everyday watch it's
easy order online today for free
shipping free returns in a 24 month
warranty join the movement and say no
big hand retail markups and saying yes
to great style check out MVM t watches
dot-com / birth and you'll get 50 15%
off your entire purchase that's M V M T
watches com / Bert what's up Cleo all
right oh [ __ ] here we go put me on these
me undies having a nice [ __ ] dry tank
but who do do me undies me and E
no more reason to paint your [ __ ]
balls cuz they're nice and dry you
catching some flies with your [ __ ]
dick I don't know I'm out of ideas with
that son what's your thoughts the secret
to new year's resolutions make the first
step real easy like the first thing you
do every day put on underwear this year
out with the old in with the new
step into a new fresh pair of me undies
the world's most comfortable underwear
and it's the easiest resolution you can
make head to me undies com2 choose from
a variety of styles and limited-edition
patterns for both men and women and
they'll be delivered right to your door
man me undies is the next level of
underwear every pair is made with their
signature modal fabric model Moodle
proving to be twice as soft as cotton
they don't just feel better than regular
laundries they make you feel invincible
Jesus they get bigger every time it's
guaranteed guaranteed to be the most
comfortable underwear you've ever worn
or your first pair you don't so don't
start your new year in old underwear
make a change and head to me undies comm
slash for right now and get 20% off your
first order plus shipping is always free
for all orders in the US and Canada so
for 20% off for your first order of the
world's most comfortable underwear head
to me undies comm slash / right now
alright here's the next - I'm literally
cooking a [ __ ] egg right now Club W
Club W ter gotta stop that evildoers
Club W we've all been there you come
home after a long exhausting day at work
and all you want to do is sip a glass of
wine and relax but unless you've planned
ahead you probably don't even have a
bottle in your house you already spent
enough time wandering around the grocery
store don't get lost in the wine aisle
you just end up picking out a bottle
based on the label you don't really get
it you get home and it sucks right you
don't need that please include all of
the following points during your read
I'm going to if you're right it I'll
read it well with Club W tear my daddy
owns a ranch you never have to worry
about being wine free again Club W I
know Donald Rumsfeld he actually ran the
thing is a revolutionary new wine club
that sends wine directly to your door
saving you all those trips to the
grocery store not only does Club W I
like to meet my dad he
being horsey when I was a kid send you
wine they send you what you'll love
drinking club w I'm running out of [ __ ]
to say about this guy easy six questions
quick quiz easy six questions let me
just get through this [ __ ] I'm [ __ ]
lay here six question quiz figures out
your palate so every bottle of wine you
receive is perfectly tailored to your
taste this it's leading the grade two
glass revolution they work directly with
the vineyards to cut out the middleman
which saves you money Club Debbie you
have reelect my trick how much you to
vote for Jeb could you vote for Jeb even
offers no risk guarantees that you'll
love what they'll send you and right now
club debía is offering my listeners 50%
off your first order when you go to club
daily a.com slash bird don't ever come
home with the wine that tastes like [ __ ]
again just go to club w.com slash bird
and get 50% off your first order club
bar
alright LegalZoom my [ __ ] [ __ ]
eggs are gonna be [ __ ] over-medium
what am i paul virzi what am i [ __ ]
paul burrs e now this is sane man if you
[ __ ] break the yolk that is an almond
ah [ __ ] got a big meeting today and I
broke the [ __ ] yo well looks like
just gonna be no season to wait a minute
[ __ ] that I went 1 foot to right Cleo I
went one foot [ __ ] - that's a good
deal alright LegalZoom everybody before
another season yeah get off the [ __ ]
heat before it on us a year passes take
the time to get your life organized with
legal zone do you have a family do you
own any assets or property if any of
these answers are yes you should have an
estate plan don't worry if that sounds
complicated because LegalZoom can help
legal zooms estate plan bundles they
eliminate the guesswork you don't have
to figure out on your own whether a will
a living truck works trust works best
for you instead you work with an
independent attorney available in most
states they'll walk you through your
options and recommend an estate plan
that offers the best solution to fit
your needs
since Legal Zoom is not a law firm you
can count on efficiency and value
everything is on your schedule and your
turns plus you know what your estate
plan bundle costs upfront instead of
worrying about hourly rates that's
LegalZoom has become the leader in
helping small business owners and
families with their legal needs you get
legal help and walk away feeling all
right get your life organized with an
estate plan bundles at legalzoom.com
today don't forget to enter brewer in
the referral box at check out that code
that's code burr at legalzoom.com
alright lastly but not leastly our old
friend stamps com1 great resolution you
can make for the new year
maximize every minute and every dollar
for your small business I know an easy
way to do that where Stan started to
think about how much time you you've
wasted at the post office driving there
finding parking not getting laid
stamps.com is a better way to get
postage just use what you already have
your computer and printer to get
official US postage for any letter or
package then the mailman picks it up
this sam's calm everything you would do
at the post office you can do right from
your desk at a fraction of the cost of
one of those expensive postage meters I
use stamps comm to send out all my
posters anything I [ __ ] sell up to my
shows I use them I'm a [ __ ] if I can
figure it out so can you right now sign
up for stamps com use my last name bar
for this special offer for week trial
plus awhile 110 dollar bonus offer that
includes postage and a digital scale
don't wait go to stamps calm before you
do anything else click on the microphone
at the top of the homepage and type in
Bern be you are are now back to some
throwback podcast
[Music]
I don't know if the epic [ __ ] blocks all
been defined like the different kind of
[ __ ] blocks I don't know if there's this
name strim but I got a new I got a new
[ __ ] block for you this will this [ __ ]
block is very special and a very obvious
one and I think like this happens all
the time but for some reason I've never
heard anybody name it so I'm gonna I'm
gonna kick off the creative process I
call this guy the announcer that's the
that's that's the name of this [ __ ]
block this is what happened to me I was
I did a gig in Jersey and at the end of
the night these two girls who waited to
be at the back of the line came up and
they said hey you want to go out and get
banana pancakes you know making a
reference to my joke saying if I wanted
to go out and hang out with both of them
right and the second they said it I was
like holy [ __ ] here's a [ __ ] here's
something I never had here's a
two-on-one and I can't [ __ ] do it cuz
I'm with Nia who's kidding no ku not cuz
I'm with Nia's because everybody's got a
cell phone [ __ ] camera and I get
caught oh no I couldn't deal with the
guilt about it I'll be honest with you
and I would say this if Nia was here if
two [ __ ] tens came up to me and said
let's do this I you know yeah [ __ ] it
let's do it I never did it
you know [ __ ] it so anyways so they said
hey you want to get out you want to go
out get bananas and pancakes or
something like that and then this
[ __ ] guy like ten feet or a way just
goes like you know those guys like if a
girl just comes up to you just like you
know you know I've always loved guys in
green shirts and you're thinking raise
you're thinking like holy [ __ ] this is
gonna happen there's some other guy like
five and just makes the whole fire the
whole [ __ ] room look over at you the
[ __ ] announcer [ __ ] cock-block
[ __ ] you know who would do that
if I was standing there and her two
girls say it to a guy I'd be like god
dammit
going down right side of my mouth that
lucky [ __ ] I would be like why
would you do that the [ __ ] announcer
and if you have a friend like that
alright the only way you can still hang
out with them is if he goes out if you
guys are going out trying to meet women
he has to wear one of those old ABC
bright yellow Monday Night Football
sport coats and if the girls why are you
wearing that you'll see you'll see and
that'll be that would be the funniest
[ __ ] thing ever like if somehow if he
couldn't figure out the joke and he just
thought the coat looked good and just
the whole night you just saw him anytime
you heard in the you know 10 feet away
in the bar he just looked over and you
see this guy dressed like Howard Cosell
and you'd be loud that's the announcer
he's these the he's the guy he can [ __ ]
block from like he's almost like a
sniper if he wasn't so [ __ ] loud he's
at the same distance as a [ __ ]
marksman but uh he kills it with with
loudness oh my god did that guy [ __ ]
annoy me come here
she just came in shaking her head what I
am beyond come on over here I was just
telling that story with that guy
cock-blocked me with those two chicks
out in Jersey when they were just going
hide you this story no no I wasn't gonna
do something this is the thing but I
just admitted yeah but this is what I
did admit if they were both tens I would
have done it I never had a [ __ ] 2-1-1
and you know something would you be that
mad if they were both smokin hot and the
cellphone video got out the video
doesn't even need to get out when you
got the announce today the guy he just
literally goes like yeah
they're nothing why am i a jerk silk
pajamas huh talking about [ __ ] blocking
and two-on-ones you know what it's
turning into a very honest podcast I was
very honest I said this is the thing I
said I couldn't I couldn't deal with the
guilt unless if they unless they were
both tens if they're both [ __ ] tens
give me a break let me tell you
something here if you hooked up with
Brad Pitt there's only so mad I could
get it's [ __ ] Brad Pitt okay yeah okay
you know what that would that if I just
if I just said some generic good-looking
guy if I just said some generic
good-looking guy and you and you just
said that that would have scared me but
the way you just acted like you had Brad
Pitt's phone number that doesn't scare
me
oh really okay it's going down if you
want to go live out on the street and
get the [ __ ] out of this house
absolutely but you're allowed to have
some sort of crazy 2-1-1 yes no it isn't
if you just you know because you're
thinking on it unlike like a very basic
level but if you're really but you
really think about it just think about
it it makes sense you're not gonna mind
[ __ ] me women are beautiful where we
lust after you it totally makes sense
you guys find like dicks are weird
they're gross it's all hanging out there
it's disgusting you don't want that you
know nothing you don't want that proven
time and time and again and your
stand-up and in your podcast but that's
another discussion you know what you you
just set yourself up like you're gonna
make some huge point and then you just
tapped out you know nothing about women
but but that's just another discussion
and I just don't want even get into that
so now what you just give me the face
what are you doing today lazy Nene
Kubrick working hard well you're in here
in your pajamas talking about
two-on-ones
yeah well I have to do an hour's worth
of [ __ ] here I'm coming up on it what
let me go an hour in two minutes yeah I
did already because you want to chime in
didn't do it they didn't have any this
week okay look at you I think you're a
fan of this podcast no I'm not listen it
didn't go down all right but I'm telling
you right now Nia if two tens come up to
me it's going down game set match really
you're gonna deny me that can I just buy
you some stuff Wow really yes really not
some sort of [ __ ] basketball wife
that can be placated with material
things to a point yeah exactly
okay if I'm gonna be [ __ ] honest here
come on there's got to be something that
I can buy you know something this should
be our Valentine's Day all right for the
guy the guy Valentine's Day this is what
Valentine's they should be every year is
the guy gets a two-on-one and then you
get some nice stuff cuz you don't like
that what do you know women don't like
sex you don't find like when you guys
fantasize you think about the guys in
your life you don't think about other
things come on Nia just one just give me
one you don't you don't yeah because you
don't want one you just being childish
no I'm not yeah you are you do you see
you think you think you want to hook up
with with Jake Gyllenhaal and Brad face
whatever the [ __ ] his name is Brad Pitt
Brad Brad face Pitt you just think you
do see you know what I think about me is
is like you have to hook up with
somebody famous I'm actually just
regular people see I'm down
to earth with this [ __ ] see that's I'm
saying you like stuff you like shiny
shiny things this is Neil I get a
two-on-one and you you get some some
cracked up face old man in Vegas like
Robert Redford like I used to be
good-looking when Nixon was in office no
that's not how ago she ating works now
you got to come with something else here
this is an equal relationship I wanted
to I could pin you down to the ground
right now and tickle you until you
passed out and there's not a [ __ ]
thing you can do about it that's how the
world works Nia why do you think America
is on top because we're right well
because we because because we can blow
you up more times so it's your physical
presence that's what makes it like an
unequal relationship yeah because I can
beat you down yeah so whatever physical
power let me ask you this what did you
have are trumped by my mental [ __ ]
Goliath miss suck on that red what do
you think you're smarter than oh that
was good though oh you got a good one in
and now you're storming off I taught you
well
[Music]
let's get to the complaints this week
everybody some lady just absolutely lost
her mind
hates my guts now and won't listen to
this podcast anymore and I'd apologize
to her but she says she's not listening
anymore there's no way that she's
listening despite that she wrote like a
five-page email that I'm now gonna read
she has a huge problem with me everybody
so settle it want me to wait you want to
go down to the break room go get
yourself a little coffee cake oh I can't
wait I'm on vacation I got nothing
better to do good I'll wait
[Music]
[ __ ] dogs been farting all day today
I don't know what steel is and it keeps
looking at me like dude you gotta help
me out and I keep going to take it
outside and it just sniffs the grass and
then I bring it back in it starts
farting again and it keeps looking at me
like dude I'm really trying not to [ __ ]
on your rug like I mean that's how I'm
reading her face I think that's what
she's saying I have no idea so anyways
so anyways here we go
subject your podcast is hate speech Oh
geesh
bill you probably won't read this or if
you do you will just dismiss me as a
stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] but no matter state
right there she's already draped herself
in the on brave and I'm gonna plow ahead
flag your podcast as of lace has morphed
into hate speech you used to be funny
and I could brush off your hateful
comments with the cringe and a shrug now
wait a minute if it was a were hateful
write along why would you add okay let's
just plow ahead but now you've gone too
far for me to feature a segment on your
podcast devoted to the deplorable
behavior of women is intolerable for
those of you new to my podcasts I've
been doing this segment which i think is
hilarious and needs to be done just to
get you caught up before this lady gives
me both barrels he'll because believe me
she does you know there's a bunch of
there's a bunch of shows out there that
that shine a light on men who beat their
women those pieces of [ __ ] right trying
to stop them from that behavior there's
a bunch of
out there they will talk about how who
are these guys
you know to say what a woman could do
with their body they'll talk about the
glass ceiling the old boys network and
all that type of stuff and they shine a
light on all of that okay which they
should because that is guys doing things
that they should not be doing that is
not fair to women okay but mutton so my
problem is not that they do that my
problem is that they never shine a light
on [ __ ] that that women do that is not
fair to men so recently if I can rate
might drape myself in some sort of brave
flag I've been reading these stories
about guys who are married their wife
goes out cheats on him has unprotected
sex has a kid with another [ __ ] guy
doesn't tell their husband and that by
the time he figures it out
he has to pay child support for a kid
that isn't even his and it's totally
legal and then I had the audacity to say
that a woman who would do that to her
husband is a [ __ ] evidently that's
hateful speech towards all women
according to this person all right
because she continues and oh does she
ever continued to feature segments on
your podcast devoted to the deplorable
behavior of women is intolerable how is
that any different than someone spending
20 minutes a week on a different podcast
featuring the deplorable behavior
behavior of black people why do they
always go to black people it's always a
that's just like calling me the n-word
this is no difference than slavery
that's people and other groups always do
that always do that all right give me a
goddamn break all right they she goes
women are I mean how is that a different
I'm how was how is what I'm doing any
different by featuring a segment of
women who are doing something absolutely
reprehensible to men how is that any
different than a show that focuses on
men doing anything reprehensible to
women when they show wifebeaters I don't
look at that like oh my god they're
saying I'm doing it too I think you know
something I really think you're being
really selfish
share and the fact that you could sit
here and listen to my podcast for this
long as I've gone off on fat people I
mean Jesus Christ once talked about hate
speech how much [ __ ] have I talked about
Peyton Manning despite the fact I can't
even throw a football you know if he
sent me an email I would understand I
bet it wouldn't even be as crazy as this
she says women are treated like
second-class citizens all over the world
when did I ever say they weren't and
even still in this country yet you have
no problem inciting further hate and
disgust towards your fellow human beings
on this earth how am i inciting hate
when when shosho wifebeaters is that
inciting hatred towards men if you look
at those shows and that makes you hate
all men then you're a [ __ ] so basically
what you're saying is that I'm a [ __ ]
and that all my listeners are morons
that if I call a woman who cheats on her
husband has a baby with another guy it
makes her husband pay for that if I call
her a [ __ ] that means I'm calling all
women [ __ ] you know is that what you're
saying are you saying we're all that
stupid she said right now there are men
and that is written in capital letters
Amy and men in this country still
capital STI ll discussing whether or not
women should have the right to
contraception and abortion yeah I
understand that those people freaked me
out
those people freaked me out and I am a
guy and I've never said that a woman
shouldn't have a right to that so I
don't know what you're talking about
this has nothing to do I'm talking about
these [ __ ] [ __ ] that cheat on their
husbands ma'am you know what I love
about all this how come you don't
address what I talked about how come I
can't hear what what do you think about
a woman who would do something like that
I saw us that the other day that said
13% of kids in this country are not with
their biological father meaning that not
just like you know that that their wife
got like divorced and and and then
remarried and they mean like there's a
guy either knows or doesn't know like
the woman had a kid with somebody else
while they were married like 13% of kids
I mean that means 80% of women on the
up-and-up all right god bless them
they're angels
but that 13
percent needs to be taken to task I mean
I would I mean how many guys are beating
women I would guess that probably right
around that same you know maybe a little
higher I have no idea
let's just let's say it's 20 plus say 20
percent of guys beat their women should
they not be called out and be called
cowardly pieces of [ __ ] you know and if
you call them cowardly piece of [ __ ]
would I have a right to sit there and
look at that and be like well that's now
you're you're inciting further hate and
disgust toward all men you're being
really selfish here man because I go off
on everybody this podcast is
over-the-top and it's crazy I call guys
[ __ ] on this podcast and you're being
really selfish right now and now you can
you know you make this big long speech
and then you're gonna take your ball and
go home
I look look at this look at all she's
bringing up here women are still earned
only 70 cents for every dollar a man
earns I think you guys should make the
same amount but I also don't think that
that that number is accurate $77.77 for
every dollar than a man earns because if
you include divorce settlements you get
to keep your 77 cents plus his 50% his
50 cents so then he's down to 50 and
then you're up to a dollar thirty
seventy [ __ ] yourself you oversensitive
jackass good lord
go buy a bigger bra I don't know what
your [ __ ] problem is I hope that
bugged you to that I said that that was
deliberately supposed to be offensive
all right so go [ __ ] write a letter
to [ __ ] [ __ ] hair calm cuz I don't
give a [ __ ] all right
in short we are still not equal to our
male counterparts and we will forever be
labeled the weaker sex well with that
attitude of course you will you know I
don't think you're the weaker sex I
think that that's all a myth I think
that that actually makes you stronger
you know because guys are [ __ ] idiots
and they think as they can do more
push-ups than their woman that they're
actually you know that makes them
smarter you know I don't know my [ __ ]
door bells ringing are you serious hang
on a second I gotta go up here and then
I get a I'm gonna read the rest of this
hold on
all right so I'm back little winded but
I'm back I'm back
so anyways bla bla bla bla bla it just
keeps going on and on and on and on um
where the hell is it where the hell was
I weaker sex and then she tries to break
me down psychologically but my mom not
hugging me if that's the case then I'm
sorry for you
I hate when people do that it's like
you're not sorry for me you hate me
right now okay so stop acting like
you're really sorry for me and you're
showing some sort of empathy you're not
showing empathy you're being really
selfish like I said I go off on
everything here I've never said that a
woman shouldn't make the same amount an
hour as a guy I never should said that a
guy should be able to hit a woman I've
never said that what the thing I'm
trying to shine a light too is that some
of these divorce settlements are
absolutely [ __ ] ridiculous and and
that when a woman cheats on a guy and
has a kid with another person and then
the poor sap who married her has to pay
for that you don't think that's [ __ ]
up Howard Stern just did a great story
on it uh last week somebody sent me an
email he did a story about a guy who was
in that situation and he refused to play
pay the child support and they said
we're gonna send you to jail he's gonna
go to jail cuz his wife cheated on him
had unprotected sex a to hell with AIDS
let's roll the dice with my husband's
life right has unprotected sex has a kid
he doesn't realize it figures it's his
because it's his whiz wife's pregnant
why would he think that it's somebody
else's he starts making the payments
next thing you know you know he's such
reason the kid figures out it's not his
kid and as a natural reaction I don't
want to pay for that and they're like
the law is just like no you have to pay
for it let me ask you this ma'am do you
have any empathy for that you seem to
have all this empathy for women and
women's issues and like somehow I'm
supposed to still respect you despite
the fact that you could give a [ __ ] if
this injustice is done on the other side
it doesn't make any sense
and I want to see like this is like
focusing on this issue this is an issue
for some reason that is just not talked
about whatsoever it's just sort of
accepted and I think it's an absolute
think it's absolutely deplorable I think
it's deplorable so I have the right to
talk about it you know what I mean and
if you want to get offended and you want
to be selfish and just be like well that
isn't fair what if I had a host segment
every week and all I did was talk about
wife beaters you know what you'd
probably send me email I just want you
to tell you I love your podcast even
more it is just it's you are just you
are a hero to hear a man out there just
just letting these these these cowardly
pieces of [ __ ] know that it's you be
[ __ ] but now all of a sudden I'm
talking about women who are doing [ __ ]
that you're not even doing at what point
in any of these stupid [ __ ] rants
that I've done have I ever said that all
women are doing this I never have I
never said that all women cheat on their
husbands and have a kid out of wedlock
I didn't alright do I make
generalizations
abso-fucking-lutely it's a comedy I
paint with a broad brush I'm [ __ ]
around okay
jesus [ __ ] christ stop being so
goddamn selfish okay and if you don't
want to listen to my podcast don't
listen to my podcast anymore and other
than that you know I mean go [ __ ]
yourself I I don't I don't I don't know
this is what she's doing is is a is a
pet peeve that I have like that happens
to me like sometimes when I do shows and
at the end of my shows someone will come
up to me and just be like look you know
I have a good sense of humor but but
subject whatever my [ __ ] phone
they'll just be like you know what
that's never funny that is never the
lovely Nia everybody hang on one second
hang on one second hello hey I'm taping
my podcast right now is this urgent are
you on the side of the road
we got triple-a no no I
the dog was farting and I thought I'd
had to [ __ ] in the house so I took it
outside and then it just sniffed around
and peed yeah I was a pain in the ass so
I'm gonna get back to the podcast all
right all right I'll tell you in like a
half all right
um anyways oh and then she goes on to
say that the terms I use will then cause
you know people to use so you know let's
I [ __ ] around and use these terms she
then thinks that people are gonna use
them seriously you don't Ameen and I'm
sure a few will but that's not on me
somebody who does that it's cuz you're a
[ __ ] and I like it's not my
responsibility to [ __ ] babysit
anybody once they're an adult if you
don't know not to call women these terms
okay although I will tell you this if
you know there is a time to call a woman
a [ __ ] okay
and that's when you find out that your
son is not your son and you still have
to pay for there's a reason that that
word doesn't does exist
all right all right there sweetheart so
I hope you come back to the podcast I
hope that you actually listen and we'll
respond and I don't wanna hear another
[ __ ] word out of you unless you tell
me what you think about those kinds of
[ __ ] women who do that okay and stop
bringing up slavery and all this other
[ __ ] and trying to drag all this other
crap into it alright you stay in your
own goddamn lane sweetheart
alright good lord
so to compare yourself not being able to
vote to being enslaved really that's
another one that gets so that's a whole
nother [ __ ] topic every [ __ ] person
out there just tries to [ __ ] jump on
that you know that's our n-word out go
[ __ ] yourself anything
[Music]
I can't believe you just did that why
did you flick that big right in my face
you burned off two eyebrow hairs
that's like twisting
[Music]
you